To illustrate how linear
optimization works in revenue
management, let us consider
a simple example --
a flight from New
York to Los Angeles.
In this flight, there are
two types of economy fares,
Early Bird fares that cost
$238, and Last Minute fares
that cost $617.
In this flight, a
Boeing 757 is used
that has 166 economy seats.
Demand for these prices
has been forecasted
using analytics tools,
looking at historical data
and incorporating
models like time
series or linear regression.
Clearly, forecasts have
errors, and therefore, we
need to assess the
sensitivity of our decisions
to these errors.
To illustrate the use
of linear optimization,
we assume that demand has
already been forecasted.
We'll illustrate how our
decisions on how many discount
seats to sell vary as the
demand forecasts vary.
If the demand for
regular seats is
50, and for discounted
fares is 150,
and the capacity is 166 seats,
then the optimal allocation
is going to be to sell
the 50 seats to satisfy
the regular demand, and then
we allocate the remaining 116
seats to the
discounted fare class.
If the regular demand
increases to 100 seats,
then we allocate these 100 seats
to these customers, and only
66 seats to discounted
fare customers.
Finally, if the regular
demand increases to 200,
then we allocate all of
our capacity, 166 seats,
to these customers.
While this seems
simple, what happens
if we have 100 flights with
connections in tens of fares?
We'll next see how to formulate
the problem mathematically
and solve it in a systematic
way, using linear optimization.